you'll see time to wrap it up just a few
more minutes
[Music]
that's on my house from space not
literally that my life
yep there it is
excuse me major Colvin has a theory that
he can tell who's walked in space just
by looking at it is more than theory you
keep your eye on this one to show you
how it's done
I'm so proud of you why have you done
the moon him back
you know Michael Collins of course
Apollo 11 definitely the command module
for Neil and Buzz so you know that after
he dropped them he circled the moon for
hours inside the module he wrote I am
now truly alone and absolutely alone
from any known life I am it I need to
get back out there yet know the younger
so you're just gonna have to work harder
look at you straight arrow yeah never
done anything wrong in your life I've
done plenty of things wrong really
hit me dr. Plimpton said you skipped in
your last three sessions I'm giving
everything to this program to the
mission kills me to say it but our girls
been praying consistently negative I
can't sit she's tough cookie if the
laptop not everyone can handle right I'm
pulling you out of the running floor
Orion
no if I were man you excuse me I know
what you're doing but you threw house
this is not a drill cadet grab a stuff
what are you doing with her I'm
officially beginning to worry you acting
so strange
[Music]
I'm good all systems go
it's a bike up there only players worry
anything makes sense
I hear that
you
[Music]